welcome to this video yeah this looks a
bit different here the time yeah you
know this is a new rating pool that ICC
has introduced and yeah they always had
some Rapids time controls they had 13
minute which is what i posted quite a
bit on my channel it is 15 minute
without increment though and the only
increment based longer time control that
the head was 45 45 45 minutes with 45
seconds increment which is really really
long and it turns out that ICC has gone
rid of that and replaced it with a new
time control which is 25 minutes base
time and 10 second increment this is
actually the official feeder rapid time
control so if you um watch let's say um
yeah magnus carlsen play in the official
feeder rapid world championship he would
play with that time control and this is
a brand new pool so it's like introduced
i think it's on since today or maybe
yesterday so people simply don't have an
established rating yet so i'm starting
with 1600 my opponent starts with 1600
so let's see what my opponent has
another rating tools okay it's got 13 13
something 1315 minute so it's not very
high rated it's a kind of a mismatch but
the thing is we have to get going in
that in their pool so it's nothing that
you can do so an interesting moment I
can actually take on g6 now
yeah takes pawn takes Queen g6 check
King h8 tweenage 6 check he has to go
back to g8 that looks it doesn't look
great for him um but what I do like is I
like more attacking pieces yeah I think
I rather developed a little bit more
maybe 95 coming yeah and what am I going
to do with that pool currently as i said
the ratings are canceled unestablished
but it will get um kind of we get the
typical situation with the ratings
getting can somebody just stood to the
actual playing strength and so on and
then tend to dream play in that pool
fairly regularly um because I think that
that this is really a very good time
control the games at the utmost would
last a little bit more than an hour I
know that's long but it is it's going to
be really high quality especially due to
the increment with the increment you can
be sure that you're actually able to win
the one positions and ya can draw the
total drawers there's nothing more I
mean at this year online chess annoying
then playing a 15-minute game with our
increment and then you have some some
Joker win rook against rook against
users like wasting 30 minutes of your
time it's just hate it so I'm really
glad that they got to introduce that
increment reading poor yeah at the
beginning we will have some mismatches
like this game on paper but okay it's a
matter of time until this adjusts and I
think it will be a pool that is welcomed
by many people who want to play somewhat
more serious chest let's say but they
were kind of um
yeah its rate that 45 45 is simply too
long it is really a long time I mean I
think I played one or two games with
that time control I did that's really
long 45 minute base time plus the huge
increment okay so what happens here he
went with g5 to get rid of that pin and
decision that I do understand the pin
was very annoying but jihad has weakened
his position quite a bit the question is
how to make use of it hmm yeah I think I
want to go eh form after each form keep
probably yeah is basically committed to
the move g-form know that is surprising
way it's basically blundering g5 huh
it's got nice be forwarded it really is
no big deal so i can take here first and
then take on g5 jana h-file will will be
opened up now night before it's just um
just a minor nuisance you can go to e2
for example you can take it but whatever
it's not really hurting me very much in
the HR the H file is wide open
if he recaptures which is likely i'm not
quite sure what else he could play um
yeah he took on move that looks may be
attractive on the surface it's the move
Bishop 2h7 giving a check if black takes
its Queen age seven mate but he has King
g7 and it's not quite clear what that
check has accomplished it's just one
check and after that you ask yourself if
you really yeah gained anything much
from it so Bishop age seven I'm not to
laugh leave the resins okay he just
resigned the game yeah that is a kind of
an unlucky unlucky thing i would i would
you would like to to show the whole game
but maybe it was a bit frustrated that
he got such a yeah he also got a little
bit of a mismatch GIM um ok so what am I
going to do here let's check how it
could have I could have continued and
this video also was meant to introduce
that I'm going to play that writing pool
and so on so i won't delete it even
though the PHS content is in term is
that that great so what what is it that
i would have played i think i would have
played nitrogen 5m simply taking that
porn and ya know i'm actually
threatening Bishop h7 if he does
something like that chango here and then
i can take chef and here's a check you
know checkmate we'll get a maid so he
has to react somehow to the bishop h7
IDM and so on broke eh i don't know
owpain g7 there's no real attractive
from possibility yeah ATM i can just
casts a long that's one one possibility
or can also invest one move to just get
rid of that night before idea and
continue from there
I'm a good way to play as just long
castles or maybe even f3 king f 20 gauge
for this kind of thing pile up on the
edge file it's a pawn and it's a huge
position so um it wasn't really a very
premature resignation for him ok it's a
bit early but it's really a completely
completely winning position for the
white player um what i can do is i can
try to get an additional on the second
game let's try that the rating Poulos is
very narrow at the moment there are very
few people entering it simply because
ICC has introduced that sort of cat
without telling anybody um they as I
learned intend to publish that occur
tomorrow or the day after that so can
you start it i am here I get hey I get a
game against fearless one who's who's
that let's check some a bit higher
raided 15-minute reading as 1900 so okay
let's see what we get here i'm going to
go 'if I've I want to play I want to
really um at one point I learn that c-45
I think it's a good idea to have that in
your repertoire so let's see well I have
not yet studied it but I plan to yeah
this move water is some quite
interesting White has two options you
can start with nijah 396 ng3 I can play
that immediately it has a couple of
advantages g3 for example if black goes
Bishop reform then white has some
additional ideas with later efore for
example in the 92
keeping the night flexible make some
sense one drawback however is said after
c6 um if he goes with d 4 which is the
normal kind of way to proceed um then
after takes Queen takes d5 cd5 CD 596 is
going to win a tempo on the Queen and
after it moves d 4 hits the night the
combination of the Queen on d4 and the
knight on c3 is a bit unfortunate as C
5d for those kind of Temple gainers can
be tricky all in case if it goes d for
um one point is here that if white goes
Bishop g2 then d 5 is already pretty
promising for black yeah we get that so
I'm going to go d5 now the move played
on the top level instead of Bishop g2
nowadays a snide f3 this was for example
played in a very similar position
bhavishya or not against Michael Adams
in a recent event I think it was the
chunkier tournament the gosh II memorial
the big point is queen bee three now
looks excellent for why it looks like it
wins material and it does but it's not
very good okay it's not playing that
queen bee three I go knight c6 and
sacrifice the big center pond okay here
i can take Queen takes I guess and then
96 and we see one point that I mentioned
why the combination of an early d for
the knight on c3 can be tricky I have
the opportunity to push d4 with the
temple on the night d5 to d4 after the
queen is moved yeah I probably will go
to I guess to a forum after that I can
already play deform
yeah maybe he's some contemplating Queen
D 1 so that after D for you can go nitey
form d 494 night XD for Bishop before
Bishop before check bishop d2 is a
convenient way to play provide
relatively after Queen a4 yeah this is
the this is an interesting moment d 4 or
not d for ninety four ninety XE for
Bishop before Bishop before check and
then that's a king of one man if he
plays Bishop d 2 1 i'm glad but if he
goes King to have one I wonder how good
that is because my bishop then on before
is indirectly hanging and he is some
checking my 9000 c6 of course he has
lost the castling rights but he is
pretty close to plank into g2 then I'm
not sure how how bad that really is I
wonder if firm I should play that
differently
I should invest invest a move before I
go for that d for noddy for text x
Bishop before check isn't entirely clear
bishop is six it might be a good
prattville g4 night before i can also
check first on before that's interesting
bishop d2 appreciably to naija two is ok
for him ok I'm going to start with that
move one point is that d 494 check I
have Bishop g5 isn't as an additional as
an additional idea and I don't see a
particularly great move for him now he
goes Knight f3 I think you for can be
played but night f.3d for 9424 bishops
is six check hmm
it's unfortunate so I cannot play d4 hmm
means that neither three is probably
very okay move yeah you should come
neither three then pretty pretty clearly
the best move I guess otherwise d4 is
really hitting the field is one denied a
3d 494 yeah that's a neat little tactic
mmm yeah I wonder what is he considering
Bishop g5 maybe that could be it's a
possible alternative not sure how good
that is but it's something that might be
okay I still think that D for after that
is probably good night of 30 ever looks
completely completely normal what am I
going to do after that actually that's
an interesting question Bishop c5 some
active moves like that to empty for is
simply not possible
hmm its kind of curious i really wonder
yeah I gained 120 rating points in the
first game yeah it's at provisional
reading hmm yeah I wonder I mean said
such a big decision it's not
disconnected as he oh I have some
pinning proper painting problems huh hmm
might be a connection problem white
forfeits due to disconnection what kind
of nonsense is that no I get a
disconnect oh Christ what's that and it
says his son so unlucky star yo what Jim
I don't know should I try get another
game Wow well okay I mean he had to go
here probably and yeah I cannot do this
because of 94 quindi for Bishop c6
changes the queen but
and something like that is a pretty
conventional iqp position probably
something between slight edge provided
equal I think I'm pretty active here so
I think I don't really have some much to
worry about okay so maybe let's try for
a real game third one Ed's unlucky am
still posting that it feels kind of kind
of silly to have invested like almost 20
minutes there and then not upload the
whole thing
yeah it takes a while that is the
smallest pool at the moment of course
nobody knows about it I really wonder
how the other guys I mean it was
announced that they wanted to introduce
it but there was no particular data
mentioned and I only learned of it down
by asking my technical when my contact
person down at ICC was busy with
producing videos and so on and he told
me at is active you can try it out but
it's not I did not really know that this
is the case yeah I'm trying for another
game but i cannot wait wait very very
long it's it's really late already here
and I planned like okay maximum one hour
for that video but if a new game now
starts and it will it actually lasts
longer then um yeah that's tricky okay
come on I'm going to wrap that up I'm
sorry for those kind of uncompleted
games it's a bit of a bit of a shame but
let's I cannot really label this as
rapid game number this and that but
let's just take it as an introduction to
that new time control that allows for
somewhat more um yeah extensive more um
detailed commentary and also allows some
with that ten second increment for
higher quality games again yeah thanks
for watching and I'm welcome you're
welcome to post your comments on on the
idea to post more videos with that time
control of course it's a bit unlucky
what happened to you but okay it's it's
not going to happen in the future okay
well thanks for watching